shows also get dubbed in things because
you've met is it your Spanish self
you've met Zack yes yeah is he now
the official Zack will he be doing the
lucky that that's what happens once you
get a voice internationally they that's
the one that stays with you for all time
are you pleased with him man you know
the first the first time I went to it
was actually Josh was I think was High
School Musical 3 I went to the I went to
the I'll never forget this I was sitting
at the banished premiere and and they
introduced the characters one by one
first was Corbin who played a Chad in
the movie but but he he came out and had
it had a great voice it was like ideals
me Oh Oh Mia more like a great great
great deep rich voice like man I cannot
wait to you and my voice sounds like the
girls come out and they're like my voice
gets a big introduction you know my
character gets a big hurry like turns
around for his big first Troy Bolton
line and it should be almost a Elmer
literally my jaws dropped and I was just
going seriously is this Kim is this what
is this gonna be like this forever has
it as the movie really come out we have
time to fix this is it know that that's
been your voice since high school
musical one it stays with you for
forever
no he copied the lucky one you can't
adhere well I have not seen it yet but
I'd be willing to bet that in the lucky
when I'm gonna be a marine coming out
saying
[Applause]
[Music]